all right byron yes
byron where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
i'm originally from florida that i could
remember that in north carolina
my dad was in the military so
we've been all up
this coast
how did you describe your childhood
my childhood was terrible
my dad was very abusive
he drank a lot being a sailor
every 18 months we did move so
it was hard to like get stable with
anyone
and he beat the hell out of my mom i
mean he
beat her
to the point that uh
it kind of gets me there when women
would say that
you know something said that i abused
him but i'm like no there's no way i
mean i've seen him kick her like a dog
i've seen her get a gun he gets a gun
and says he wants to kill her
every time it seems when he gets drunk
that's when he comes in wanting to fight
or we you know we look in the closet and
we see he has uh
a lot of female pitchers in there where
he's doing all his porn with all the
other sailors and then it seems strange
you come home and you take it out on
your
wife accusing her of someone and
you know right then she would have three
or four kids
and that that didn't work you know he
just had to come in and fight
do you ever take out on you as well
yes yeah we have whoopings i mean he
whipped us with everything from
extension courts
to the curtain rods
anything he could get his hands on he
would line us up
and he gets the whale
i have wepts on me right now
blisters do you know
to verify what he went through and what
people say today is child abuse
there's no comparison
and so he did it to every one of us
and so that made us grow up
to us we're thinking we was
normal
but you know you realize you it was very
dysfunctional
and i realized as i gotten older
he didn't know any better because he um
got married at the age of like 17 18
going into the military
and so
that's all he knew
as far as uh
the discipline and from the south
that's a whole another package because
they believe in putting their hands on
you in order to keep you in line
did you make it through high school
uh yes i jumped i dropped out at the
10th grade
uh because
all of them moving around i really
didn't
get a hold of the school work
because you have jobs
yes we went i went to a lot of trade
schools so right now you know i uh do
different jobs as far as brick masonry
or working on houses plumbing and all
but um
that was part of the
the thing that it got me as far as
getting the education is because of the
abuse i couldn't not concentrate
because you know you're wondering if
your mom is dead
you know what are you going to go
through when you get home
and so i felt the seventh grade and when
i did that i had to do a repeat and i
tried to get everything there so i ended
up dropping out of 10th grade and
getting a ged
and graduating at 18 around the same age
and
i had taken up trade school courses
um you know plummet woodworking electric
stuff like that
because he always told me i wasn't going
to be [ __ ] anyway
and so
that didn't really help
but it in the long run it made me more
determined to show him that i wasn't
going to be like that
you know he criticized all of us
and to my brother now the oldest one
he's been married four or five times and
he still can't hold down a relationship
and the one under me
they both picked up the abuse
to me i feel if you got to beat them you
don't need them
but i don't really have time to be
having the feeling that you'll go
through with that
so i just
with me i've been in a car accident so
what i do now i uh work on cars as much
as i can do what light work i can and
then i uh deal with houses
and
you know try to make a couple of dollars
here and there told you
i'm
61 now 61.
you've been married
yeah yes i got married at uh 18.
and i was married for 13 years
and i binged that i was uh
younger at that my wife was 17 years
older than i was
so i ended up getting into
uh the language of me now it was an
abusive relationship as far as that
and a lot of manipulation because you
know
18 years you know sight into you getting
married you
giving your all
you know working two jobs and
you're trying to be successful
and a lot of the things you know started
and not working as well because um
starting it's hard to make ends meet
when you're only one working
and being the sole support of everything
well i thank god i didn't have any kids
at that time
you have kids now
yes i have a daughter at this point
and um
she loves me very much she's uh 24.
and it's pregnant finally
i'm glad she didn't do that as i was
constantly behind her not doing that at
a young age
because getting education
is always the first because you're gonna
be out of work
and dealing with the people in your life
if they walk out like i had to go
through the things with my um
first wife
you're gonna have to do the struggling
to get back up
because at that point i um
i had a couple of vehicles
and i was just more or less on the you
know materialistic thing and being on a
materialistic aspect
you get to
not looking at life for what it really
fully has to offer
is the uh the lure of getting rich
strong with you
yes having money was the um
utmost thing it's very important because
in trying to raise a family
and trying to take care of yourself
as well as trying to take care of your
uh my mom
i wanted to make sure that she didn't go
through
the same crap that she did when i was a
child
you know i made sure as before she had
passed i
sent her on vacations
to the bahamas
every year paid her gas bill
i made sure her tank was filled up so
she didn't have to go through trying to
go through in the wintertime in north
carolina
they had a gas tanks there so i want to
make sure that she was comfortable
because someone had frozen to death when
we was a child
and i didn't want that to happen
and my dad had already had passed
and by that time i had went through
a 13-year marriage and went through that
disappointment would you describe the
way you grew up as living in poverty
definitely
yeah we never really
had what the other kids had
we stole bikes
when they was um
rich enough to leave them outside on
their lawn
you know we seen it we'll take it and
try to
paint it up and whatever
like they're not gonna notice their bike
again you know your brain is not so
developed
did growing up poorer than your
friends make you feel inadequate
yes
most definitely you feel inadequate
because you can't have what they have
you know it's and well i come from a big
family my mom had
six boys and two girls
so with that when you come home
you're not going to have much of
anything you're going to wear
hand-me-downs when you turn around and
your brother finishes you hope you tear
the pants up and you hope you could eat
enough beans to fit in it because a lot
of times that's what we had to eat
you know you get a pot of beans and
the beans will last us a week
and that's what we had to go to get
through the month because the beans in
this beans and that and this and that
the beans was the main filler that and
some cornbread
and so we would go
see commercials in the stores of you
know and go into stores and we would
just start
stealing
and uh
that's how we started getting what some
of the other people had
and that just led me into a uh
worse life as i went into my teenagehood
when did gambling start for you
the gambling started
right when i was married i started
getting around there and started wanting
more and more
and i didn't let her know
because i didn't want her to
you know
leave me
so what i would do is just come with
these excuses
to why i'm over here why i'm over there
where i'm going with my friends
or you know we start playing pool
and you're broke
so your story like you know i bet you
this
i'll bet you that you don't have a
diamond in your pocket
but if you get lucky
and then you win
now you have something
so it's like real
i i won
i got this
thank you lord and you take that you
move to the next one
and the next thing you know
it's a great feel it's a high
it's like one of the best highs i've had
it's way better than alcohol you're
sitting up here broke and then you could
give someone there so i could get my mom
this i could do here
take this and go get me this or that and
the price of things was so high
and they're working it takes so long
sometimes to get the money but gambling
you can get that in just i just say a
couple hours half an hour 15 minutes at
times
what's the most you've ever won
well the most is ten thousand
when you have people working with you
like you know you're gonna bet because
you when you're placing bets
you gotta make sure that you can cover
it
so when you're doing that
then you're winning
and they keep pushing you up
i'll say 10 000.
so when you have a payoff like that
that becomes a
constant goal for the future right
that's scary when you get your share now
you're going to walk around with a
couple of thousand
and the other person is getting theirs
but you got to get out of there
no but every time you win you think
you're going to do that again tomorrow
almost definitely
most definitely when you go to sleep
you that's all you drink it's a good
feeling
especially if you go in there you're at
atlantic city they're going to comp your
room
now all of a sudden you get food
you just wake up and it's like wow
yeah baby we
got this
we don't have to worry about going
asking anyone for anything and you start
dreaming about the other things that you
can get and that's what the hardest
thing is when you start dreaming about
okay now i could get me a better car
i could go ahead and get we could get a
better house
and the worst is when you go ahead and
you start putting your paycheck out
there to it now you're coming home and
you broke
you win some
and you lose but the winning is what
makes it worthwhile
because when you're coming home with the
money and everybody's happy
that's a great feeling and yes you've
been gambling for how many years i keep
going back i had 30 years
gambling
on
everything kind of what kind of
i've been doing the cards
i love blackjack
that's one of my favorite
and the casinos when i go there with the
um slots
i mostly like to do the higher slots
like five dollars you go to atlantic
city yes oh i've been to atlantic city
to the point all i could keep hearing is
the chimes and
the money hitting
the bottom of the thing
and walking away with a bucket full of
coins
that is great giving it to them
and get that cash
and go out and just enjoy yourself
buy you some nice clothes i have four
cars and a truck
i own my house
and the wife was happy
then but then it turned around when you
go through the losses
that's the part that's hard
tell me about the losses
i've lost everything
i
lost my wife
she ended up walking out i
went for help that
gambler's anonymous
that didn't work
i could remember getting up at night in
the middle of the night
running out thinking okay
i could run to this spot
maybe they're open
and i could go ahead and make some more
money
maybe i could take this 20 and turn it
into 200.
sometimes you can't do that
but then you're there all night
then you have to go to work what else
have you lost
you lost your wife i lost my wife
i've had four cars and a truck
i lost them
i watched the
the mortgage go back so we have to sell
the house
i went through a
second relationship
and that's the one that i end up having
my daughter with
i didn't let her know
that a problem
and uh
you know i just let her know i was
working
so she thought that uh oh he's a busy
guy yes i am
and then it turns around
i end up losing that relationship
because of gambling yes
yep because the gambling because at
first you turn around i mean
the women come with it too
you get the nice places to stay you get
nice women
you alcohol drugs the whole nine
everything
but one of the hardest is when you know
you have to do the payback because even
on fights i've gambled on fights
i forget them all the football games
hockey
you get good at that
you get real good at that you get to
looking at the odds of this and that
the racetracks i love the racing
auto racing
camel doing that too
and it's one hell of addiction when you
run into cars watching your cars run
around running around
and you you actually could
win if you get good at watching your
cars and knowing the drivers
i have one
i want a couple of hundred here there
but if you stand back and look at your
record of wins and losses over the over
the decades
oh i'm sure you've
done a lot of losses
oh yeah yeah and what gets me is when
you look at what you put back
and
that's when i try to not even think
about
you know when you could win
two buckets of coins five dollar coins
you carry them like this
like here
give it to my wife to carry it like that
and you turn around and you put it
you get it cashed in
and then you go stay overnight
and you could enjoy that week i remember
that time i enjoyed the whole week but i
went back home i came back to philly and
then i went back
and what i had left i ended up putting
it back in
so i just borrowed the money for a week
and then i was like you know
your dreams for that week
all that you think you're going to be
able to do because you i'm thinking now
if i use this system
and then i'll go ahead and bet you bet
50 on here or you could go ahead and bet
20 over there then bet five
and no bet two
that two bet two bet two they bet five
and then go bet twenty and then you know
that's what keeps you because the
payoffs would be good and then it'd be
bad but then okay i lose that much
and by the time you continue playing
that little game
you don't spend hours in there
and now you turning around the sun's
coming up
now you got to figure
now what am i going to tell my boss
ah [ __ ] now there you go again
now i'm trying i got another problem
now i'm going to lose my job
because i don't want to quit
i'm thinking i could actually look if i
could make this
amount in a week dealing with this man
but if i could make this amount in maybe
a couple of hours
or just you know at the pull of the
slots or just at the flip of the card
if that card flips in his mind
like three of a kind all right
i could win i don't have to worry
i could take the year off if i act right
i could go take a vacation
but i tried to budget it like i said to
help my mom as well so i wanted enough
to cover some ends but then by the time
i look at the whole aspect of it
i end up spending more
out
because now what i didn't accumulate it
i'm ending up losing
because now i i had to pardon stuff
go to the pawn shop and
one of the saddest parts was telling my
wife i needed to pawn her in
and um
that wasn't good
that wasn't good at all that's a hard
conversation to have
i didn't even want to face her with it
then you got to feel like a heel
feel worse than dirt
then i even had with my daughter at
times that uh i would promise her stuff
and um
i can't come through with it and i would
have to make an excuse
well you know
this happened that this this happened at
the job
a baby a lot i told my wife one time i
had lost like about 500 i told her i
lost it one time i told her i got robbed
yeah i told her i got robbed
how does all this
gambling and losing
mostly
affect you emotionally
it makes you
hate yourself
at times you beat yourself up i do
you feel worsely i'm just like you just
just
like a worthless piece of crap
because you feel like
people were better than you because how
come they could have the will power to
walk away especially somebody that's
sitting over there gambling
and they know okay they got a limit then
they go with the limit like i had people
say well i only carry
800
i only carry a thousand dollars i know
when to stop
whenever i'm out i'm done
when my thousand dollars run out
i'm mad
i i
it's like a crack addiction
where's the next one
where's the next to this
like another drink i gotta have it i've
got to have it
i've got to try to hit again
i'm looking over at the progressive and
it's like
wow don't i don't look look at the
pictures
of the people that's one they holding
this check
even on facebook they try to hook you up
with oh if you're saying this you can
win
i want this when you see what somebody
else don't want
that just does something in your head
now you want it
that means there's a chance
there could be a chance for me
even though they try to tell you the
statistics of the billions of people and
that that
but
maybe i could win i would going with the
stretch offs and stuff at one point
trying trying
two dollars
four
i even had my wife trying to gamble one
point
to the point she started getting hooked
then i knew we was in trouble
because you could tell then that it
makes you feel like well it's not that
bad
but really inside
you you know it's something's wrong
you just can't quit
you just wanna gamble on anything that's
gonna pull you some money
and that's the way i am
i just want something that's gonna take
me from a
to see
you think it's it's the poverty that you
endured as a child that you're trying to
fix quickly
yeah
most definitely that's that is the
i'm tired of being down where you got to
ask somebody for this it would cure your
self-esteem issues
yes i've been stealing just to pay off
some gambling debt
i end up at one point end up going to
prison
getting caught stealing to pay off a
gambling debt
and so i'm sitting up in here
looking at my life going
this is crazy
this is how bad i am that i i'm in
prison so they don't kill me out there
are you still gambling today
yes
yes i do i try not to gamble as much i
don't gamble as much as i used to
because i don't lost everything
i had nothing to gamble
gamblers anonymous
i tried
i went there
and i made it for about
i would say
30 days
and then you listen to the stories too
again and
a lot of them
you could reflect and
say i was there i i could relate
i know what it's like
have your woman think he's cheating
they sway you cheat
i think i took a car at a car that they
had liked
so
what i would do
is um
i would rent the car out
for money to gamble
i figured if uh all right well here
you take my car you give me
30
for eight hours
to bring my car back or it's going to
cost you this amount
yeah
and one time i had a girlfriend
and um
after i was mad about with women after i
got up
separated after the 13 years i figured
that i lost everything and what the hell
i had to
offer so
i got hurt
[Music]
turned tricks so i could take money and
gamble
and
that's how that one went
come on there and
help get her some clients and the men
liked her get it dressed like this
and um
[Music]
go under the l
bring back somebody and pay somebody to
pay a certain amount at the door
go ahead and turn the tricks and give me
my money so i can go ahead and go out
there and gamble
and i look at it now
and um i could kick myself in the butt
because i i had a daughter so once i had
a daughter i started looking at it
differently
and that's what helped me slow down a
lot
is having my daughter
and trying to do the right thing and
guiding her
as far as you know looking
up to a man
and so
then she looks up that as me as being a
man daddy i'm trying to show her the
kind of man that she should be so i let
her know my mistakes i let her know my
weaknesses
and i let her know i'm sorry and certain
things i just can't help i
i
i tried to rehab she don't like you know
me gambling
she told me that she told me how
dangerous it is and
it's bad
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently what regrets do you have
i always fight not to be
drinking
i would definitely fight not to gamble
i'm not i wouldn't want to do that
and i would want to save money i wish i
was more of a saver
and more focus
on the directions in life in which that
i should be
because i turn around and let a lot of
things
materialistically throw me off course
and that's what really a lot of it is
that and
companionship
dealing with a
wanting a female
a lot of times you go through
sacrificing a lot a lot of
your own character
and that's a lot of the things that i
still struggle with now
because that's one of the main things
that uh deal with
having you get angry at a relationship
then now i go again
i'm going back out there
sitting here gambling beating myself up
and chasing women
and going drinking beer and stuff
are the same old thing just out of anger
and that's one of the problems i really
have
is getting angry directing it
my anger don't have a direct direction
that's going to be productive
and the only
thing that my anger actually does
is hurts me
i'm the one that end up
ultimately paying the price
all right byron thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you very much for taking the time
to listen
i wish you the best of luck
but not at the casino
thank you
thank you
stay away from the tables
you